hello everyone and welcome to a video
where we will be discussing uh a burning
question in the chess world nowadays uh
is magnus crossing going to defend his
uh world church championship title in
the next world church championship cycle
that will take place in 2023
so of course we still don't know who the
challenger is and i think that will play
a big part of it we still have to wait
for the candidates tournament to play
out and then we'll see what happens
because if you remember uh after the
match uh uh against danny pony she that
magnus won very convincingly he said
that he's very unlikely to defend
his title in the next world championship
and another interview was conducted with
magnus um i believe a few days ago by uh
tares vincent for the for the norwegian
television uh it has been translated in
english so if you guys want to check it
out i will put a link in the description
in the description below it is on
chess24 uh but basically what magnus
said is that if there is anyone who
expects and still hopes that i will say
yes to playing i will have to prepare
them to be disappointed and he also
points out that um
uh i wanted to quit while on top and
it's clearly what's most likely to
happen but who knows i have changed
opinions before but when i have the same
feeling for too long it rarely changes
back so no i'm not closer to playing a
title match than i was uh after the
world champs uh chess championship match
so now that being said it still doesn't
seem that the public is convinced of
what magnus is saying uh just earlier
today i think some five hours ago i
created a twitter poll uh where i asked
is magnus will magnus defend his title
in the next world church championship
match and okay the poll is supposed to
be 24 hours but already uh after a few
hours you can see that uh 76.7 percent
of you
are
thinking that he will defend his title
regardless of what he's saying and only
23.3 percent are saying that he will not
defend his title so i am very much
interested in your opinion in this
and uh well feel free to share that
in the in the comment section as well
now i also thought as this is something
that i haven't done on the channel so
far maybe you guys would be interested
in what the history of the world chess
championship looked like so okay we're
not going to go back to the really
really old days of the of the you know
chatarangi in chaturanga and and whatnot
let's stick to modern chess and we're
not going to go back as far as i don't
know joaquin greco or philidor uh but
maybe some era that predates uh uh video
matches so it is um
basically
divided into four parts so the first
part is the unofficial world
championships where uh players would
would just agree to play a title match
for the world championship and the rest
of the community agreed that that was
indeed a wheelchair championship match
so in the old days and that is uh
basically what predates 1886
uh where uh wilhelm steinitz uh became
the the first official affiliate world
champion uh you had uh uh la bourdonne
you had pierre saint-amand then you had
howard staunton you guys all know him as
we've covered him extensively uh during
the morphe saga we didn't see a lot of
his games but we spoke quite a lot of
him
then you have the legend adolf anderson
after him you have uh of course i would
say an even greater legend paul charles
murphy uh then of course wilhelm
steinitz himself and johannes tsukertot
uh and um they were considered to be the
strongest players in the world at the
time that they were playing okay morphe
uh resigned uh his uh title or basically
he just stopped playing chess so it took
a lot of time for the for the official
world championship championship to be
organized and only after morphy's death
did we get the first uh sort of official
feeder world chess championship match
even though
it wasn't a a fide world championship
match it was still
the players agreed they would play and
they would play it was not organized by
fidei so you had the steinitz winning in
1886 against
johannes tucatort he was actually the
student of adolf andersen and he shared
his playing style then um stanis after
winning that title would hold it for i
believe some eight years uh imano alaska
would uh win the title from chinese in
1894 and he will hold the title for a
staggering 27 years that is the longest
anyone has ever held the
world chess championship title uh when
he is finally challenged in 1921 by the
great cuban jose raul capoblanca we've
covered that extensively during our
capablanca saga so if you haven't seen
it do check it out i will put
all of the links that are needed in the
description below
uh so uh you can see that
if you guys have watched the saga that
the match itself wasn't all that
interesting but the negotiations that
led uh to the match were
just incredible and uh
alaska didn't face capablanca as the
world champion he resigned the title and
then he challenged capablanca as the
challenger and kopa blanca won that very
convincingly then uh if we uh had
continued in this direction then you
would have alexander alejan who takes
the title away from jose rocablanca six
years after that in 1927 and he holds it
uh basically for the rest of his life he
does lose the title uh for a very brief
time in 1935 uh the the dutch grand
master max uda uh defeated alejandra
wins the title back two years after that
in 1937 and uh holds it until his death
in 1948 i believe sorry in 1946 in 1948
uh the the great tournament was
organized by fidei to decide who will be
the next world champion and basically
there we have the uh start of the era of
defeated world church championships that
starts uh with the great uh 1948
tournament that is won by mikhail
botvinik uh only five players um i
played in this tournament uh uh between
us mislove keras uh you had the the the
younger chevsky and the max uva and
botvinnik won that uh tournament i would
say uh very convincingly and then
botvinic had quite a lot of uh title
matches he he uh lost his match in 1957
to vasilis mislove he wanted to ride
back then he lost his world championship
title to mikhail tal in 1960 uh then he
won it right back in 1961 then in 1963
he finally loses it for good uh tigram
petrosian who holds the title until 1969
uh where he faces boris posky so boris
posky becomes world champion and then we
have the match of the century in 1972 of
course if you have followed the bobby
fischer saga then you know that in 1972
in iceland reykjavik bobby fischer uh
wins the title uh by defeating boris
spassky in uh one of the one of the
greatest matches and one of the greatest
stories uh what i believe uh were ever
told so if you haven't seen it do check
out the fisher saga as well yeah it's a
kind of a
it belongs to some of my older videos so
the videos are only at 30 frames per
second but i hope you don't hold that
against me it's
quite quite enjoyable and then what uh
is supposed to be the greatest match
after that the 1975 match between bobby
fischer and anatoly karpov
never actually happens as bobby fischer
decides not to play for the title he had
quite a lot of uh well the sort of ideas
that should be fulfilled
for the match to ever take place of
course uh
fide could not uh
oblige and then the match never took
place but if you were following the
bobby fischer saga you kind of had this
uh well sort of a
premonition that even though uh spassky
was uh fisher's main opponent it was
always karpov who was sort of becoming
stronger and stronger in the
back of the story because uh in the
training camp where uh spassky would
would train for the match with fischer
he had a lot of grandmasters that he
could train with uh like mikhail tal he
had the uh uh leibniz was there and even
the very young anatoly karpov and if you
guys remember when they were playing and
sparring uh karpov would often beat
spars uh spassky and he would um uh
he he got very angry that spassy lost
some possessions that they clearly
discussed uh
while preparing for the world
championship match against bobby fischer
but okay uh in 1975 uh karpov becomes
the uh world champion without actually
playing the world chess championship
match and he holds it all the way to
1985 where he is defeated by the one and
only uh gary kasparov who holds the
title uh for a very long time but now we
reach what is sort of uh the the dark
ages in in chess where
uh chess is divided you no longer have
just defeated world championship cycles
uh you have defeated world championship
cycles and you have the classical world
chess championship cycles or so they
will we're called andrean association um
uh well started by kasparov the
professional chess association and then
we had dual world championships you had
world championships uh of one
organization and you had the world
championships of other organization so
uh first kasparov uh and the nigel short
broke away uh from feeding and then
played uh they played the third world
championship match in 1993 uh that
kasparov won and also kasparov uh faced
uh vishwanathan anand under the flag of
the professional chess association in
1995 uh and finally in the year 2000
kasparov loses his title to vladimir
kramnik to the amazement of everyone i
believe even kramnik mentioned that he
was amazed that he actually won the
match but it was um i believe the first
time that kasparov faced uh someone who
was also
preparing with an engine because the the
engines weren't incredibly strong in
those days but you could use them very
well
in some positions i guess and that match
is very well known as the the berlin
defense matches kasparov faced the
berlin defense so many times and he just
couldn't break through uh in the end
kramnik won by i believe a two-point
margin and kasparov did not win a single
game and uh also uh under the flag of
the professional chess uh
pca professional chess association uh
another match was played in 2004 kramnik
played against peter leko uh the game uh
the match ended in a draw and i believe
uh kramnik retained his title uh and
that's what was happening in the
professional chess association but in
defeated wheelchairs championship uh
cycles you had a lot of world champions
only some of them here i'm going to name
no i'm going to name all of them in 1993
you had anatoly karpov in 1999 you had
alexander khalifan in 2000 you had
vishwanathan anand 2002 ruslan ponomario
of 2004 uh rustam kasim jhanov and in
2005 you had vessel in the polyp and
finally this sort of dark arrow of chess
ends in 2006 where the associations are
once again merged together and in 2006
we have the uh again the original fiji
world championship where
uh uh wesleyan topolo faces vladimir
kramnik and kramnik defeats him you
probably remember this match as there
was quite a lot of talk about this match
uh for for some some very uh funny
reasons uh but yeah in 2006 we have uh
kramnik as the world champion then he
loses uh his title next year to
vishwanathan anand and alan holds it
from 2007
until 2013 when he finally loses the
match to magnus carlsen uh we've covered
that match if you guys haven't seen it
it's a sort of a short magnus carlsen
saga uh and we've discussed it quite a
lot there are some very interesting
facts even i even discussed on uh you
know stuff like what magnus ate before
the match so if you haven't seen it i
will also put a link to that in the
description below so you are welcome to
enjoy that so basically since the merger
of the professional not the merger but
since uh you know 2006 when we have only
defeated worlds championships uh we only
had uh
kramnik anand uh and magnus carlsen as
the world champions and the magnus has
sell the title uh ever since 2013.
so next year it will be his 10th year as
uh as the world champion and he defended
his title successfully he defended it
against uh sergey karyakin he defended
it against fabiana karwana and he
defended it against uh iannipomishi as
you've seen
as a
in the last one but also uh after losing
the match in 2013 vishwanathan anand
also qualified in the next candidates
match uh tournament and uh challenged
magnus again uh as the challenger this
time magnus also uh defeated him there
we have not covered this match but i am
planning to cover it uh at some point i
i think we've covered like two games
from that match which brings us now to
2022 where uh magnus is still
uh undecided on whether he will defend
uh his world chase championship title in
the next match now it would be it would
be of course a shame for the chess world
if that were to happen uh anyone uh who
is uh in in the uh candidates tournament
deserves uh a shot ah at the champ and i
think uh no one would uh everyone would
be incredibly disappointed if they won
the candidates tournament and they did
not get to face magnus because uh
imagine uh okay i don't know what the
uh
what the concrete procedure will be if
magnus just resigns the title will the
winner of the candidates tournament
automatically be declared as the world
champion uh but it would be
i don't know
imagine if if let's say duda wins the
candidates tournament magnus doesn't
want to play uh duda is now the world's
champion
uh the problem is he would face the the
he would uh face the same fate as
anatoly carpo because when anatoly
karpov became the world champion without
facing bobby fischer he had to prove uh
years and years and years on that he
deserves to be called the world champion
because in everyone's eyes of course
bobby fischer was the world's champion
and
of course that's not um not something
you want to do so it's uh you know
there is no greater privilege of of
facing uh a a world change champion so i
hope that doesn't happen and uh
especially okay since magnus said that
if someone like alireza wins that he
probably will play or maybe not probably
he's still undecided but that would be
definitely a spectacular match but
regardless who wins the candidates
tournament imagine if hikaru wins the
candidates tournament i mean a hikaru
magnus classical world chess
championship i think that would be the
uh most viewed event probably on the
entire planet if you consider uh
you know both magnus and hikaru the the
the number of following that they have i
think that would be
it would be such a shame to deprive the
chess world of uh such an event
uh but yeah i just uh you know thought
i'd walk you through uh a short history
of the world chess champions um all
right so hope you guys uh enjoyed that
and you can see that there were quite a
lot of them and that um
all right it's a very very uh
interesting story uh and i hope that it
doesn't end by magnus um just uh you
know resigning his style and you know
whoever wins the candidates is is the
next world champion uh but yeah uh
that's that was just a short overview of
chess history so hope you guys enjoyed
this and as i usually don't uh i make
videos without showing even a single
game since this was all this is already
quite a long video i decided to show you
a really short one this is from uh doha
qatar in 2015. it was a blitz tiebreak
game between yuangi and the magnus
carlsen so it's an extremely short one
but a very very funny one so i hope you
guys will enjoy this one uh so yeah you
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 magnus plays knight to f6 we have c4
e6
uh knight to c3 and bishop to b4 so
magnus goes for the names of indian
defense knight to f3 with b6 preparing
to fiance to the light square bishop and
e3 so a bit of a different style than
what we currently play today
where you have the immediate queen c2 or
e3 or even a3 challenging this bishop
but okay uh bishop to b7 we have bishop
to d3 and now both players castle
castles castles and magnus strikes in
the center with c5 as you know you
usually do and now we have this knight
to a4 move which is very odd but it is
the absolute strongest move recommended
by the engine here
but it also shows you how you have to be
very very careful when you trust the
engine about what is the absolute best
move here magnus plays c captures on the
e4 e captures on d4 and now as he knows
that this bishop will get attacked he
plays rook to e8 this rook will be very
useful on the e file and also now he has
this f8 square to retreat with the
bishop with a3 bishop to f8 and now
bishop to f4 and already here uh if you
consider this move and another move that
we mentioned uh your spidey sense should
be should be tingling now so here magnus
plays bishop captures on f3 queen
captures on f3 and now knight the c6
going after the d4 pawn and of course
yuyungi uh exten
advances his pawn to d5 captures
captures attacks the knight and now
knights the e5 and here you pretty much
have to capture the knight you give up
the dark square bishop and then you play
something like knight to c3 and
everything is perfectly fine however
after knight to e5 attacking the queen
uh you played queen back to d1 and now
i'm sure your spidey sense is already
giving you the correct answer but if not
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations uh on spotting this
uh well a wonderful idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is the very simple knight captures
and the three queen captures and of
course rook to e4 uh the bishop is
hanging and the knight is hanging and of
course it was in this position on move
16 that young resigned the game as he
has to suffer uh a severe material loss
uh so you can see while knight to a4 is
not a mistake in itself nor is bishop to
f4 uh this simply allows
of course if this was a classical game
or something uh longer or maybe even
rapid and this would not happen but if
it's a blitz game and you uh you know
put your put your pieces on uh funny
squares then uh things like this will
happen and yuang is uh who uh world
renowned grandmaster of course this is
something that would happen to him uh
maybe once in a thousand games but in
this game it did happen and of course
magnus spotted it
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it and that you've enjoyed this brief
overview of uh the history of the
unofficial and official and you know uh
dual world chess championships and then
again united so i hope that was uh to
your to your satisfaction uh i would
like to thank uh uzongo
nagarjuna ponogoti dave ellis pratt
and us of the efri for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else is
happening in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and feel free
to comment on your opinion whether
magnus will or will not defend his title
in the next world church championship
match
see you soon